SCP-682 Vs SCP-217.
Could the clockwork virus finally be “time’s
up” for this unkillable reptile?
SCP-217 was pumped into SCP-682’s cell via
a gas pipe.
At one second, SCP-682 was sitting still.
At seven seconds, the gas was introduced to
the containment area.
At 21 seconds, SCP-682 was coughing, as the
virus traveled into its respiratory system.
For nine days after this, SCP-682 had no visible
response to the virus.
However, at 224 hours, 36 minutes, and 24
seconds, SCP-682 began to howl with pain.
The roaring continued for 35 minutes and 48
seconds.
At this point, the screams began to quiet
until SCP-682 went completely silent, and
appeared to be in shock.
After 36 minutes, 682 began to laugh uproariously,
apparently having developed an immunity to
the virus.